thank you
[Applause]
I am not just humbled of that I most
certainly am I also feel like the
luckiest man in the world to be standing
here as a leader of the SNP a party I
joined almost 20 years ago and that I
love so dearly if elected as your first
Minister after tomorrow's vote in
Parliament know that I will be a first
Minister for all of Scotland that I will
work every minute of every day to earn
and to re-air your respect and your
trust
I will do that by treating you the
people of Scotland with respect
there will be no empty promises or easy
sound bites when the issues in front of
us are difficult and complex because
government is not easy and I won't
pretend that it is
my immediate priority will be to
continue to protect every Scott as far
as we possibly can from the harm
inflicted by the cost of living crisis
to recover and reform our NHS and other
vital public services to support our
well-being economy to improve the life
chances of people right across this
country I'm a pro Scot and equally a
proud European too and Scotland is a
European nation we want to return to to
the European Union and play our part in
building a continent that's based on
human rights on peace prosperity and
social justice
we will be the generation that delivers
Independence for Scotland
where there are divisions to heal we
must do so quickly because we have a job
to do as a party we are at our strongest
when we are united and what unites us is
our shared goal of delivering
Independence for our nation